we'll get five topics then we'll drop a
beat and have some fun if you are sat in
this section what would you like a rap
about
mole person love song Thank you very
much it feels like you've been waiting
your whole life for someone to do that
I'm so glad I could come along and
oblige
this tranche here what would you like
what did you stoicism for cats
what the [ __ ] is going on here
because I I like to know what gig I'm
going into and I ask one of the comments
and I was like how the crowd they said
that genuinely a really nice crowd I was
like great but you're [ __ ] weird mole
person love songs stoicism for cats what
there was another person who said
something
dying did you say death and dying
death hands dying death and dying more
person love songs stoicism for cats look
the next two suggestions you can't [ __ ]
up because
these are god-tier suggestions
these are up there with some of my
personal favorites like 9th century crop
rotation and Afghani irrigation ditches
let's go what do you want to rap about
the the
RK which was a genuine you didn't think
I knew about this it's a genuine war
that was fought in Australia between the
settlers who wanted some land and the
emus that lived on the land fun fact the
emus did not lose the war it was if you
look this up on on Wikipedia it's pretty
much a stalemate there was even an
injury on The Human Side
someone accidentally shot themselves
right
fun yeah you're surprised I knew that
but then again right more person loves
song death and dying the Emu War because
I misheard you at first I misheard the
emo War I was like I've got a little
Paramore fan in the back [ __ ] My
Chemical Romance yeah [ __ ] them
[ __ ] him and stoicism for cats this
section what do you want to rap out
claustrophobia Great Well Done um you
know what annoys me when people say I'm
agrophobic which is the fear of they
they say it's the fear of the opposite
of classroom a fear of Open Spaces
tender words agoraphobic right
agoraphobia genuinely is the fear of
sexual assault there you go just add the
O say agoraphobic never say agrophobic
just you've got to put it in because
we're all agrophobic I believe uh deep
down inside
claustrophobia claustrophobia stoicism
for cats the Emu war death and dying and
mole person love song fueled by illegal
drink this it's like we're in the 1920s
yeah let's make sure the pro is don't
come in feel an illicit thrill running
through me
because you may think that this is like
a hot caffeinated beverage in fact I was
in a bar drinking a beer and then I went
oh I have to come here but I haven't
finished my beer and I said would you
like us to put it in a to-go cup
and that's a crime that's illegal
and I did a crime
I'm here on a green card I could be
deported this is
I'm a rule breaker
I mean look the Queen's dead I can do
whatever the [ __ ] I want
[Applause]
yeah
um
I didn't even like the beer it was too
Hoppy
if I'm gonna drink it cause I'm a big
boy
[Laughter]
DJ Armstead if you could drop me that
sick little beat
let's do this
yeah I'm glad you're also politely
excited
[Applause]
bad rap would have left you crying I'm
gonna ring it out why cause I'm death
and dying I focus on this I've got a lot
in funeral directing stuff I'm in the
coffin it's how I make my cash how I
make my skrilla I'm not Jack the Ripper
or a serial killer I'm just put in the
ground six feet under dead people
stealing the Thunder plunder all the
graves D and D not Dungeons and Dragons
actually that's a lady with the sun
there in the basement I've got a problem
you know I'm gonna chase it I've got a
tiny little cat it survives persis why
cause it's got nine lives try and look
at this in the feline prism back in the
day the Greek store is Schism when for
sure I see Mr Center car he says gotta
live a life ever so pure connecting to
death got a value every day imagine if
that cat went away how would you deal
with that you'd say Well I'm glad I had
the little moggy in my life not bad
that's how you be a stoic even and if
you get exiled to an island nor wet from
the tears you can still enjoy your life
we're moving over here rap about a lady
wife or some other type of thing yes we
can say keep her in a box not a copy
natural labor if she's in there you know
she throws it up she's claustrophobic
gets her bones Frozen up says Ah I can't
face it Please Release Me From the small
spaces it's ever so difficult you know I
lost it I'm in there maybe trapped in a
closet that's an R Kelly reference I
don't know why Jesus Christ you're like
me oh my but I talked about the sexual
assault and so it linked in my brain
it's not my fault what we gonna do have
a lot of fun I've got a person I love
deep underground they live round there
in the hole go with star nose tiny
little mole living underground and they
never see the light they're like no one
will love me throughout my life what am
I going to do I feel so bereft you to
have a boyfriend but they left I'm in
here I feel so crazy I get on Tinder I'm
the mole lady and I see her you know I
like her the more lady why so a swiper I
go and visit her there in a little Den I
say whoa girl you're a 10 out of 10. and
we start doing it she likes it large she
goes yeah yeah you know we're [ __ ] in
the dark she's really good and a mole
[ __ ] type I know he'd be sick but she
can't see the light wanna go to a
nightclub get a nice rub she's pretty
cool yeah digging with a thumb in my bum
I like it a lot the mole person starts
humming on the male G-spot this is
genuinely very unsettling there was one
thing remaining one thing left in remind
me I had too much fun rapping about them
whole person's Thumb in my bum what was
the last thing that we do
foreign
just one person say because if you all
say it once it's just like a massive
noise
of course how can I forget
but they say oh yeah we could have lost
it but we won emu strong [ __ ] the
ostrich those ones black white feathers
in the day I prefer the emus beige and
gray they'd be there in Australia I'll
say to you the accent they attack it
they aim for sure ah [ __ ] we're gonna
melt them down in their hordes all the
emus alike now up yours we're going to
defeat you you'll be bereft we're really
[ __ ] dense and our flesh chips
absorbs all the bullets from the Gatling
gun we've got really long legs you
should watch us run and we do we
dominate yeah he'll say [ __ ] Australians
for killing emus every single day
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]